well i let me start by
saying a few words before i talk about
our guests about
russian ukraine
i've uh i had a
productive talk
last week with
president zielinski and we continue to
engage in non-stop uh diplomacy
and to de-escalate tensions and attempt
the devil to improve
security for our allies and partners
and for all of europe for that matter
and today in the united nations we've
laid out the full nature
of russia's threat to ukraine's
sovereignty and the territorial
integrity
of ukraine as well as the core tenets of
a rule-based international order
and we uh we continue to urge diplomacy
as the best way forward
but with russia's continuing its
build-up of its forces
around ukraine
we are ready no matter what happens i
also want to note that the uae
defeated a ballistic missile attack
launched by the houthis
separate issue from
yemen yesterday
and we've been in daily contact with the
uae to address
those threats and i've directed
secretary austin
to do everything he can to communicate
the support
of the united states for the uae saudi
arabia and throughout the gulf region
america will have the backs of our
friends in the region
today but i'm honored to be here with a
good friend
who
has been wonderful
relationships since i've been president
and then before
the sheik
50 years of partnership
you're not that old 50 years of
partnership
and this past year our partnership with
karera
was has been central to many of our most
vital interests
relocating tens of thousands of afghan
afghans uh
maintaining stability in gaza and
providing life
saving assistance to the palestinians
keeping pressure on isis and
deterring threats across the middle east
and a lot more and
and the amir and i have a lot on our
agenda today we want to talk about the
security of the gulf and the broader
middle east
ensuring the stability of global
energy supplies
continuing our work together
to support the people of afghanistan
and strengthening
commercial and investment cooperation
between our two countries speaking of
that
on that front i want to applaud
the new
deal that qatar airways group signed
with boeing
for 20 a 20 billion dollar deal
one of the largest deals that following
aircraft has ever had
and it will support tens of thousands of
good paying u.s jobs here in america
cutter cutter's a good friend and
reliable and capable partner
and i'm notifying congress that i will
designate cutter as a major non-nato
ally to reflect the importance the
importance of our relationship i think
it's long overdue
and i want to thank you again
uh
for being here and for making this trip
for you uh your commitment to our
friendship and between our nations and
i'm looking forward to our discussion
today
well thank you very much mr president
good afternoon to everyone i'm very
happy to be here mr president 2022 is a
very important year it marks the 50th
anniversary of our diplomatic
relationship between qatar and the
united states of america it's a very
strong relationship and we're very proud
about that we're very proud that we have
achieved
of course this afternoon i'm going to be
talking with the president about
different topics
mainly about the security
of
our region i think we demonstrated that
how solid and how strong we can work
together cooperate on what we did in
afghanistan we're very proud that we
managed to evacuate tens of thousands of
people of
afghanistan of course we have other
issues as well that we're going to talk
about the equal rights of the
palestinian people
and other issues
in the region so you know we're very
happy and proud of this great
relationship and we're going to continue
working together
to find ways and means to bring peace in
our in our region so thank you very much
for
you know seeing me today mr president
and as you mentioned that we'll be
talking about
several topics
thank you guys let's go thank you let's
go thank you thank you thank you
thank you hi let's go thank you thank
you
thank you
thank you very much
she hopes make progress